do you think we're going to go back to
five days a week again back to the
pre-covered normal is that where this is
going no we're never going back there
unfortunately for these companies that
are trying to mandate this back to the
cubicles the Genies out of the bottle
there's a whole cohort a whole
generation of employees that have proven
over a three-year period they can work
functionally very well not in the office
and so you really have to ask yourself
where's the empirical data that says
productivity drops if you're not in an
office and that's the challenge because
we're still at full employment in
America any anything under four percent
unemployment is full employment Mr
Wonderful here and there's no debate
about this small businesses in America
create over 60 percent of the jobs but
times are tough is there a solution yes
the government employee retention credit
program go to wondertrust.com today